one of the most recent films I did in
America was about the rap scene in
Florida where it's quite difficult to
have a conversation that's not about
money right in fact to carry a huge
wedge of of of of dollars or like $100
bills like that and press it against
your head is one of the cliches of the
genre right you literally will have uh
jewelry around your wrist around your
neck designed to advertise how much
money you have and a great Icebreaker
should you find yourself in Fort
Lauderdale or Miami interviewing a
SoundCloud rapper or a gangster rapper
is um I love your jewelry like how much
did it cost and and they'll be very
happy to tell you and the com you know I
was you know I was 100 G's I don't even
know if cheese is the right term forgive
me for my slang but um and the
conversation will proceed very smoothly
from there and I think in America in
general probably uh the money
conversation is less taboo right I think
that it's interesting but only up to a
point and I think it's interesting in so
far as other people find it interesting
it's interesting what once you you once
you have enough money right then it
becomes a source of relief you have the
freedom to not really worry so much
anymore right to not worry about whether
you're going to make your rent or be
able to pay your bills and you know
there are decisions that then take place
about how you make sure you don't lose
your money what you do with your money
what portion of that money you should be
um donating towards good causes and
otherwise how much you need to set aside
for your family all of those are very
personal decisions and probably worthy
of a program in its own right and
certainly like a a a responsible company
that could advise you on how to make
those decisions that would be a
brilliant idea but um I think for me for
me it's like it's a measure and talk to
Stuart after the presentation um for me
it's about uh I'm interested in metrics
of um oh of of of how people consider
what's important in life and and metrics
of you know what's interesting to me is
like if n Rogers says he has 500 million
but he's not happy right he seemed very
happy by the way and and and and and and
stresses and the psychological issues
that come along with you know positive
and otherwise that come along with the
decisions that go with having a lot of
money I you know so my tip for listening
we were talking a bit about this
beforehand is is is just to find some
something that you're interested in but
it's very hard for me to advise on that
because there's a sense which comes so
naturally to me like I just like hiding
I like the feeling of invisibility that
you get when you're talking to someone
and they're just downloading whatever's
in their head does that make and I again
this may be too much information but
when I was growing up my big worry was
like God I don't think I'm very
interesting because I don't have
opinions about anything and I'd much
rather listen to what other people have
to say and you know that's changed as as
life has gone on but I genuinely do
find um other people's perspectives
fascinating and and I do find that the
world's such a strange and in many
respects a lonely place and that by by
finding someone and connecting with them
and realizing that in unlikely ways you
can you just find you just sometimes it
takes a little work but with a little
bit of digging you find oh the person's
recently gone through a divorce or
they're bered or they were an orphan and
they were adopted and and there there's
some fascinating part of life that you
get to and and and that you can learn
from and that makes you feel a little
bit more at home in the world
really